Most people who are watching have the
ability to be curious about an area that
seems perhaps far-fetched, but if
it went the right way, could change the
world. And you might be surprised
because right now it might just not be
sexy. It might not be in the zeitgeist,
but that that might actually be a good
thing. Like that might be your
opportunity. Whereas building the 17th
AI SDR might raise you your $2 million
seed round, but like
This is Dalton plus Michael. Today we're
going to talk about the thing that I
believe
is the secret killer
of startups. And it's not what you
expect.
It is low ambition. We work with a lot
of startups. Let's talk about ambition.
And let's talk about what happens when
we work with a company that has low
ambition. It is extremely
counterintuitive because you're
>> like, man,
I've heard from the world and I've heard
from these guys how hard startups are
and like only a tiny percentage of
people succeed.
>> Therefore,
>> let me try to like increase my odds of
success by aiming way lower. And if I
try to just build like a small little
startup, that's going to be way easier
than trying to build the next Google,
which sounds very hard.
>> Yes.
>> Right?
>> That sounds intuitive, right? But our
evidence um suggests that is not the
case. Also, it's not creative. This is
actually what pains me the most about
this thought. It's not unique. Yeah.
We're making a video about it.
>> Like yeah, you're not the first person
to come up with this insight.
>> If this insight worked, you would see so
much success.
The fact that you don't see it, like
this is why I hate first principles
thinking sometimes. It's like
the fact that there's no evidence to
support this is
damning evidence.
>> it would be like, well, Michael, there's
lots of small businesses that aren't
venture funded that are
>> That's great. Yes, but there aren't a
lot of venture funded small businesses
that make anyone any money.
>> Correct.
>> And we've had decades to to experiment.
>> That's
>> Yeah, so I guess the I guess to
steel-man the opposing point is that
>> Okay, well, then I guess I should not
raise venture capital if I have low
ambitions. And I think we would say,
"Yeah."
>> Sure.
>> I think point granted.
>> There it is.
>> Yes.
>> Almost nothing in this video
we're going to talk about is relevant to
a un-venture funded company.
>> Fair.
>> But if you are going to raise money
>> Yes.
>> of any sort at any stage
>> um
being low ambition
>> toxic
>> bad.
>> One of the so weird about being low
ambition is it goes in the category of
things that you'll almost never get
feedback on.
So, it's like when you go to a VC pitch,
like
that no one's going to be like, "You
know, this like you're just not brave
enough." Like it's just like it's almost
weirdly insulting to tell someone. And
so, like
you might get weird feedback like,
"Well, you're not how you don't have
enough users or this, your TAM's too
small." And and the reality is
the world doesn't change enough if you
win
to be interesting.
>> Yeah, almost like the way I would
try to frame this for you all is
if you're going to
do something hard all the odds are
stacked against you and you there needs
to be a lot of invisible hands that lift
you up and pull you forward of people
that see what you're doing
>> Yes.
>> and try to help you perhaps
irrationally.
>> Yes.
>> And there are way more invisible hands
pulling you up if you're doing something
really ambitious and exciting
>> Yes.
>> than if it's just like ho-hum, who
cares.
>> Yes.
>> The faceless army is not going to help
help you.
>> Well, it's weird because it's almost
like the world wants
big new things.
>> Yeah.
>> The world wants it. Like it's like
entropy is really working in your favor.
Weirdly.
>> If you have a big dream, most people
will respect you for having a dream.
>> Yes.
>> And if there's small ways they can help
you on your personal journey,
>> Yes.
>> they will do so.
>> Especially if that dream clearly makes
the world a better place.
>> Yeah.
>> This must be some weird aspect of just
being human.
>> Yeah.
>> Where like you just kind of
want the world to be a better place. You
want to help people
>> someone and they were like, "Michael, my
goal is to eradicate cancer.
I want there to never be cancer again.
No one should ever get cancer." A, okay,
great. Like again, I would I would be
like really excited to
>> Exactly.
>> Yes.
>> I would have questions. Oh, well, how
are you going to do it, you know?
>> Sure.
>> Um, but man, what a cool mission.
>> Yes.
>> But if I met someone and they're like,
"Michael, my goal is to improve
click-through rate of ads by 0.05%
that are rendered on mobile
through the use of novel AI."
>> Again, might be a might be a business,
but much harder for that to stick in my
mind of of um a mission or a vision that
I'm super excited about.
>> Well, and let's be clear.
Yes, and
there are many software examples for
that, too, right? In my mind. So, let's
not just use health healthcare, I think
it's easy, right? Like cancer, but like
hardware / software examples,
self-driving cars. Software example,
like
What?
>> Yeah.
>> Like the AI products that are giving
people superpowers.
>> So, when Gmail came out,
I believe Yahoo Mail gave you something
like 10 megabytes of storage.
>> you had to pay. I think default free was
like three or something.
>> Yeah. And then Gmail was a thousand.
>> Yes.
>> And that was on purpose. It was it was a
hundred X better than the alternative.
>> Yes.
>> And so for a lot of products, we would
always recommend uh to YC companies
trying to be a 100x better
>> Yes.
>> is like the bar you should be going for.
If not, why bother? Why bother making
something that's 2% better than the
alternatives?
>> It's really hard to convince founders
that this secret hand is working in
their favor.
And like it's something that we've seen
in hindsight, right? Like the number of
secret hands that were helping OpenAI.
>> Right?
>> Many.
>> And I think this is something that
I personally learned from Sam, which is
that basically it's like
you can tell people these stories about
how you're going to do this thing that's
going to make a lot of money without
having this little impact, and like they
might actually believe you.
They just don't care.
And like what's weird is that like to
win, you need a lot of people to care.
You need customers to care, you need
investors to care, you need employees to
care, you need co-founders to not leave.
Like you need care.
>> Care.
>> Yeah.
>> The more ambitious you are, the more you
want to make your customer life a better
place, the world a better place, the
more people have reason to care.
And
that caring is a variable you get to
control when you pick your idea.
>> Yeah. I I don't know if this will
resonate for you, but I almost think of
a startup or any organization
as like a battery or a flywheel or an
engine.
>> Yes.
>> And you want it to be so strong
>> and have so much velocity and torque
that it can pull forward all of these
different people, all these different
customers, all these stakeholders
because of just like the strength of
this thing.
>> Yes.
>> And if the the core engine is weak and
doesn't have much torque,
nothing is going to happen.
>> Yes.
>> Because you're having to pull You're
having to pull the world a different
direction.
>> Yes.
>> And so a very ambitious idea, a very
ambitious approach into what you're
doing.
Has the shot, it has the horsepower and
torque to to pull something forward.
>> I want to add to that. You don't know
how many times other people pitch your
company.
Right? So, when you have that hero or
that a champion inside of a company that
you're selling to, they have to go pitch
their boss and their co-workers when
you're not in the room.
When you're raising money, that partner
you're talking to, they have to pitch
their partners and their LPs, right? The
employee, they often have to pitch their
parents,
>> Yep.
>> their spouse, their friends when you're
not in the room.
How good of a pitch you giving them?
>> Right?
>> Are we changing the world or are we
optimizing click-throughs by 1%?
>> Yeah, I um I met Elon in like 2008.
That's like the only time I ever talked
to him.
>> Yeah.
>> And in the first 30 minutes of talking
to him,
he told me the following line,
"My goal
is to die on Mars,
hopefully not on impact."
Clearly he uses that line a lot.
>> Yes.
>> But it stuck in my mind when I met him
as
>> Almost 20 years.
>> what an interesting ambitious person and
he made a big impact. You know, again,
like I I certainly remember the time I
met Elon Musk and that was way before he
was, you know, famous the way he is now.
>> Yes.
>> And that simple story that is that
ambitious and clearly he just told
everyone that. Like it wasn't that I was
special. He just walked around life and
would tell that to every person he would
talk to.
And I'm arguing that's how you manifest
>> Yes.
>> the kind of stuff that he manifested is
he would say crazy provocative things,
he would back them up,
>> Yes.
>> and there were all these invisible hands
of people, you know, he would just keep
putting that story out there
>> Yes.
>> and got people to work for him, he got
people to give him money, he got people
wanted him to win.
>> And like I think that like what sucks is
that sometimes the press and like
history
can turn all of these stories into like
the big man.
Like, oh, and then he hand-built the
robot. He hand-built the rocket and he
welded and it's like
all of these are team games.
>> He told people a story that they could
believe and sink their teeth into and
and devote their lives to that vision.
>> they joined his team. And even the
people who didn't work there
were still
>> Who's buying the stock?
>> Exactly. They're still part of the team.
And so it's so weird to think that like
>> I'm telling the story. I'm part of the
team.
>> the team, exactly. Exactly. So it's
weird to think of these people that are
held up as these individual greatness
people who really their skill
was building the largest teams.
>> Yep.
>> Their skill was understanding having
high ambition allowed them to build the
most exciting
largest team and that team would power
them to fulfilling the ambition. You
know, I I come from politics world way
back in the way. Like, you know what
that sounds like to me? Obama.
Right? And it's like we're going to get
a black guy with the last name Hussein
to become
Or middle name, sorry. Like we're we're
going to we're going to need a team
here.
WE'RE GOING TO NEED
A POWERFUL TEAM. And
I think that, you know, a lot of people
talk about great companies are
movements. Like so hard to build a
movement off of improving click-through
rates by 1% by using AI.
>> Yep.
>> And what's sad and unfortunate is that
you will if you have a good, you know,
if you have decent co-founders, you go
through YC, blah blah blah. You'll be
able to raise a seed round.
Right? Like if you do yada yada amount
of revenue, you're probably going to
raise a series A.
But no one's going to tell you in the
back of your mind like, yeah, after that
no one's going to care.
And you need people to care.
>> Yeah.
>> So
let's put this in the context of AI,
because like hilariously
I think
I would have assumed with AI ambition
would have gone away up.
But this whole talk of like
single-person company, like I don't
just there's some stuff in the ether
which in my mind is like making
Sometimes I feel like ambition's going
down. And I I What do you see there?
>> think it's
because we're in a market cycle.
If the way you're keeping score is
what's raising money,
>> Yeah. Yeah, that's a good point.
>> to get weird ideas. Cuz remember in in
2021, all sorts of stuff was raising
money. Think about all the unicorns.
Every every 24 hours there'd be a new
unicorn minted. And you'd be like, "Wow,
I can't believe Remember Cameo was a
unicorn?" Like, "Oh, I can get, you
know, C-list celebrities to say stuff.
That's the future."
Again, actually I like Cameo, but that's
It It was probably not the most
ambitious idea in the world.
>> No.
>> Um and so if you're keeping score on
what's raising money, you can get really
warped ideas about what good is.
>> Yes.
>> Um and I'm I'm just trying to argue this
is going on in AI land. It's like kind
of like everything's getting funded.
>> Yes.
>> And so you're like, "Oh, yeah, I guess I
guess my like
15th version of the same thing that
other people have done is a good idea."
Tricky.
>> Tricky.
>> No, it's it's definitely
interesting as well because ambition
high ambition doesn't mean the road's
going to be easy.
It doesn't mean that you're going to be
popular especially early.
>> That's a great segue.
Let me give some specifics because I
think you could be watching this video
thus far
and be like, "Man, I should just pitch
some like really crazy sci-fi ambitious
stuff and like these guys will think
that's really smart."
>> Um not necessarily. So let me let me
give the nuance.
>> to kill Nvidia.
>> Yeah.
The
ambition has to be combined
with a simple pitch
>> Mhm.
>> and a pitch where the logical leaps you
are making
are intuitive and that you are credible
at making those logical leaps.
>> Yes.
>> Okay? And so, when Elon was talking to
me about dying on Mars,
I at that time he was running Tesla, he
knew a lot about hardware and in my
conversation with him, he talked about
all the ways that like NASA was
underperforming. So, actually there was
quite a bit of substance in my
conversation with him about how he was
going to actually do it and his argument
that the thing that was holding back
space colonization and exploration was
institutionalized slowness because it
was run by the federal government.
>> Yes.
>> So, he had a whole There was a lot
there, guys. Um
and that is how you make
a credible pitch.
>> Yes.
>> When we heard Sam pitch OpenAI, he
actually knew the researchers that were
doing the work and were recruiting them
to work on it.
>> Yes.
>> was all based on papers that were coming
out that were being written. Yes. It
wasn't Sam just being like, "Oh, I'm
going to make magic AI. Give me money."
>> No.
>> There was a whole lot of substance
there.
>> Yes.
>> And so, if you're watching this and
you're trying to
triangulate what, you know, Dalton and
Michael are saying about Ambition, you
have to root it in things that you know
about and make very simple
low leap of faith arguments on how
you'll be able to do it. That is so
important for Ambition.
>> I love that.
But I want people to understand that
that might not be as hard as you think.
Right? Like AI wasn't the buzzword it
was it is today 10 years ago.
Figuring out who the leading AI
researchers was was a was a question of
curiosity.
It wasn't a state secret.
Figuring out what the leading papers
were was a question of curiosity. Like
I'm not saying that Sam isn't incredibly
talented. I'm saying that like
understanding how broken NASA was was a
question of curiosity.
>> Yes.
>> Like there
>> SpaceX the the NASA people always like
this will never work. Like like he had
naysayers out of the gate which was the
actual experts being like this is the
stupidest thing ever the whole time.
>> So I think that like
you know, most people who are watching
have the ability to be curious about an
area
um that seems perhaps far-fetched, but
if
it went the right way could change the
world and you might be surprised because
right now it might just not be sexy. It
might not be in the zeitgeist, but that
that might actually be a good thing.
>> Yep.
>> Like that might be your opportunity
where else building the 17th AI SDR
>> Yep.
>> might raise you your $2 million seed
round, but like
>> Well, and in both of these cases, maybe
you can think of others, it involved
disagreeing
with authority figures and conventional
wisdom.
>> Yeah.
>> Like it basically required
looking dumb.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> To experts.
>> So you would need the combination of a
credible argument that you could explain
and sit down for half an hour and like
walk through all the pieces.
>> Yes.
>> And have it be an idea that has been
discarded by experts that it will never
work.
>> In fact, you know, we're talking about
the difference between
being ambitious and being a scenester.
>> Yeah.
>> I think these are some of the tests,
right? I think you know, we kind of
think about a scenester as someone who
wants to play the game of startup but
not actually do anything, you know?
>> Correct.
>> Their their ideal is to be on a panel
with you and Musk not to change the
world.
>> Yeah.
>> And I think a scenester would be one
very afraid of being looked down upon by
experts.
They want to be embraced by experts by
day one and I think a scenester is
afraid of ideas that aren't sexy.
>> Yeah.
>> They want to be part of the zeitgeist
immediately. And so, I think when
thinking about trying to work in a
company with high ambition, you have to
be careful, right? Like, you want to
make sure you're not working with
someone who's pretending
to be high ambition.
Maybe the last piece of advice on this
front,
imagine that we're talking to a founder
and he's like after they're like after
hearing this, but I don't know if I have
this level of ambition.
What What do we tell them to do? Yeah,
so this is again might be
>> surprising advice from us, but to the
extent that you have no idea how to make
your startup ambitious, it might
actually be more fun and fulfilling to
go work somewhere where that is not the
problem of the organization.
>> Yes.
>> And then maybe it'll come to you later,
right? There's a lot of people that
worked at very ambitious places that end
up
I mean, a whole string of ambitious
ideas later.
>> Yes.
>> But it's not obvious spending your time
working on a low ambition startup idea
for years is like actually
a good idea.
>> You know, I'll try to coin a new phrase
like ambition pilled, right? Like
we've certainly worked with founders who
have been inside of companies and seen
what a company can do.
And be like, well, if this company can
do this, like I can make a company. And
it's crazy sometimes when you meet, you
know,
talking to a founder who was involved in
figuring out like how to make um
Starlink work. And you're like, can you
imagine just working in a company that's
like, well, we're just going to
put all the satellites up and have
global internet. And then
they did it. And then you're like,
oh.
Wow.
>> I I think the way I would riff on this
is basically we've seen so much wacky
stuff work because of our jobs.
>> Yes.
>> We're extremely convincible.
>> And part of our um value add as
investors was to be like, "Hey, we've
seen a lot of people make stuff like
this work. You should definitely do it."
>> Yes.
>> And that is helpful
>> to hear from someone that is an
authority figure to be like, "Hey, this
This sounds as crazy as other stuff I've
heard working you should try it."
>> Yes. Yes. And I think people will find
that surprising. I think they would
expect us to be like, "Well, but if it's
a B2B SaaS thing for this and da da da
da it's more likely to get funded." And
it's like
that's not really our KPI.
>> No.
>> Like whether it can raise a seed round
is not
the KPI. Um like whether it can actually
make a big difference in the world.
That's really
Those are the companies you care to be
helpful to.
>> And when you have limited time
all you're doing is searching for those
companies.
>> So, if you're watching this, one, you
have our permission as the authority
figures obviously to have as much
ambition as possible and to make the
world a better place. This road's going
to be hard regardless so you might as
well make the world a better place. If
you're concerned by your level of
mission, go work some place with high
ambition.
And like you're you you can be
ambition-pilled and like we've seen it
all the time and we certainly see so
many founders who come through after
working at a place like that and they're
like, "Now I'm confident I can make a
big difference, too."
And then last but not least, do not be
fooled
by the scene-sters, by the fake people
out there. If they have the tagline that
you mentioned with Elon and then have no
backup in the Right, it's like if the
first minute of the conversation's good
and the next
>> Yeah.
>> 29 minutes you're like, "Oh, this person
seems
maybe move on."
>> Yeah. May- maybe my final parting
thought is if we call back to the tarpit
concept which you and I have talked
about before
>> Yes.
>> the ultimate meta tarpit
>> Mhm.
>> is getting caught in a low ambition idea
that you know in your heart can never be
big. You know in your heart you're not
even excited.
>> idea.
>> You don't even You're like, "I
You're going through the motions
explaining it to people. If you burn
years of your life on something that you
think is a waste of time in your heart
of hearts that is a true tarpit.
>> That is a true tarpit.
>> You got to get out of there.
>> I love that. That that is the meta
tarpit.
Oh, man.
>> All right. Great chat. All right.
Thanks, Michael.